o latitude pessoal daqui que falou dar
que seja muito bem 20 é mais um vídeo e
o estrago de que ninguém que basicamente
um jogo inspirado no clipe pasta é o nós
temos que identificar o homem da meia
noite e sobreviver dentro da nossa
própria casa até às 3 e 33 da manhã e
bem pessoal este ou barrar completamente
a cueca por isso prenuncie estou honrada
cueca já sabem foi nossa janela já pagam
todas as luzes deixa o volume no máximo
fucri no vídeo e vamos buscar a cueca
juntos só hoje do que pode ser um
caminho estranho porque eu tenho andado
muito doente mas não liguei minha voz e
por lá em jogada pessoal stark moc é eu
já te ver aqui algumas coisas sobre joe
e sei que existem aqui umas pequenas
regras que o povo já explicar não é isso
faz tudo parte do clipe pasta é ok e
instruções pré-requisito é os materiais
necessários incluem uma vela é a tua
porta principal de madeira pelo menos
uma gota do teu próprio sangue e um
pedaço de papel e fósforos
ok passo 1 escreva o nome completo o 1º
de maio eo último ano um traço papel e
meti meta pelo menos uma gota do seu
sangue no mesmo deixou deixou absorver
algo assim percebo o que é paz 2 desliga
todas as luzes dentro da casa vai para a
tua porta e coloca o papel com o teu
nome em frente dela
pega na vela e acendia paz 3 bate na sua
porta 22 vezes
é hora tem de ser meia noite até ao
final da última batida uma coisa sem
partido ou seja nós vamos ter que bater
22 vezes na porta e neve gesto em uma
segunda vez
tem que ser exatamente à meia-noite eu
acho que é isso ok sobre a tua vela e e
e nessa altura já o midnight - está
dentro da tua casa ok paz quadro
imediatamente sua vela e estas regras
pessoal ficar aqui mais um pulinho eu
ficar aqui outro carro é para lá que não
estava em mim está pronto agora sim ok e
instruções
os dois devem andar pela casa
completamente escura é com o o o vela na
mão o de o objetivo é evitar o homem da
meia noite é tudo custo até exatamente
às 3 e 33 da manhã
ok é esses o teu o setor vela a pagar é
porco minutemen o homem da meia noite
está perto de ti tu tens de acender a
vela é nos próximos dez segundos
ok se não conseguir fazer isto é o homem
da meia noite vai induzir alucinações do
teu do teu maior medo até às 13 33 da
manhã
ok tudo isto continuar até às 13 33 da
manhã sem ser apanhado pelo pelo homem
da meia noite o homem da meia noite vai
sair às 13 33 da manhã e e tu vais poder
a insegurança pela pela mãe é uma pessoa
desaparecida é ficar no mesmo sítio o
jogo todo
vai e vai resultar da enfermidade em que
o homem da meia noite vai encontrar
ok é altamente recomendado que contínuos
é o verde durante o jogo é isso pessoal
não sou muito bom em inglês mas acho que
consegui traduzir assim mais ou menos e
agora pessoal eu tenho uma lista de
coisas é não fazer que é
não hã hã hãe não ligar qualquer luz
durante o united game não usar uma
lanterna durante o game não dormir
durante midnight gay me a não usar o
sangue de outra pessoa no teu nome é e
não usar uns cairo com um substituto da
favela é isso não vai funcionar e
definitivamente não provocar o homem da
meia noite em qualquer circunstância e
basicamente estas suas regras pessoal
para nós conseguimos de enfocar o homem
da meia noite por cima de uma coisa
calma jogar futebol mas o futebol é
trabalho o carioca e eu preciso de umas
coisas
e eu acho que tem uma caixa de fósforos
na cozinha e eu deveria eu procurar na
cozinha pelo resto dos meus dias têm
jockey apagar as luzes uma uma irá ser
doloroso eu acredito que existe um
ruptura geral é fora da casa de banho ok
é f para apagar a vela e botão direito
do rato e não right of light sa botão
direito do rato para bater na porta o
capital one show aqui se lembrar é o
ritual não é da ale folha exato a cair
funai e nem o que escreveu não completa
na folha de papel lula blá blá blá
ganhou quem já preveja precisarem sair
do papel
assim não é cozinha é cozinha é que
estamos fortes e que transforma os
postos estão na gestão a não não estou
bastante confiante uma faca ou calmo eu
ganhei isto o pessoal não faltou ice-t
vela está o esforço só que a pj já
percebi eu peguei uma faca e agora falta
nas velas fósforos que está agora eu sei
que posso estou aqui o resto dos itens
também supostamente a crise aqui ok
boxing day kitchen né exato exato tom
que hoje temos todos por isso eu tenho
procurado aqui pelo menos a caixa de
fósforos caí calma andar caixa de
fósforos e e é vela é isso que falta
pessoal para conseguir fazer um ritual
para invocar o bicho e não cobra falta o
que revela a falta dela ok agora fica a
pergunta se não conseguir o inverso
também como é possível isso faz-se
exatamente viram só como é que se fosse
de vetar neymar pró-reitor encontrei ok
ok ok encontro revela encontrei ela está
pousada da nice
ok pessoal ou cai agora eu quero eu
quero sendo ela não é no f1 não é fácil
é da luz alta queda
não está a pagar o iof para pagar a cair
fósforos fotos os juros baixos
acho que é o pessoal conta que acender a
vela e agora dei deixem só ver que as
regras o que era preciso mais para lá eu
escrever o nome completo ano num prazo
papel do vilão em um pedaço de papel com
calma e ver que o nosso papel aqui na
rua e ver o que eu vou escrever quinto
meu nome
antónio ramos e sensual este é o meu
nome é ver nada e agora precisam ter
aqui o que eu precisava do inter sonhar
já se recusara a calma calma não é
preciso ler é preciso e eu tenho de usar
aqui e falar que eu acho é é conseguir
sair agora e agora supostamente já não
lembro mas já não me quero fazer meu pai
para abrigar os lusos têm que pagar as
luzes mas espera perder por cima de uma
coisa para o caí a um interruptor geral
é fora da casa de banho e fora da casa
de banho fora da casa de banho o cão da
casa de banho de ser aqui meu esta porta
de madeira eu acho que vou ter que usar
aqui
calma não tinha um quarto eu acho que
vou ter que usar aqui numa destas portas
não é um quarto mas eu quero é que eu
tenho que ir à casa de banho e isto é
isto não está conectado não está
incluído geral é que o egito desde que o
técnico também paga o cara só aqueles
doces todas e agora falta não falta um
ter o papel do relator não era porque o
gato falta manter o papel na porta de
madeira está ok isto é vidro de vidro
metal papel e conseguiu agarrá-lo o o
consigo agora consigo não sei por que eu
experimentei estudantes e que vidro de
uma porta
em sua fala sério pessoal estava
dormindo na porta de madeira estava
jogando estava o que é meu é estudar lá
fora estava lá fora eu vou ficar
estático beast entrante que o cara não é
deixem sua vez esta porta de uma ideia
porque também o texto chama noite
qualquer pessoa chave no esquema e noite
achei muito bater na porta calma
e apareceu lhe 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
22 e agora esse parece parané ao cras
que fica aí acho que ficar igual não
espero que se viu isso não não
ok pessoal ok eu fui muito lento eu fui
muito lento eu fui muito lento
fazer isto o cap só lá vou tentar outra
vez eu pelo menos tenho que conseguir
invocá lo então bora lá ok agora tem que
fazer tudo novo aí tem que vir aqui o
papel lá
antónio ramos
agora tem que ir lá encontraram a faca
exato tac faca tom que os fósforos
i o candeeiro o candeeiro novela estava
aqui não
agora a linha deve estar aqui dentro das
gavetas mesmo
não que eu acho que ela não ficava ali
mas pronto ao abrir a porta do
frigorífico nada ok eu acho que não aqui
traz não está conectada a porcaria da
vela meu em cima não está logado
além de talento já vi time o que é isso
eu acho que tem tudo eu que ensinei a
vela
ok só é seguir os fósforos é muito
complicado é muito complicado no poço
que está o senhor boa já só tem 2 mil
dois fósforos o gado
ok e agora vou ter que manter o sangue é
isso lá exato corta muito bem muito bem
jogado dos arquivos vai agora até lhe a
porta e não serão aceitos por ser nesta
porto na outra eu não sei se foi por eu
não ter assinado a vela que eu morri mas
pronto
jackie ainda está aqui eo exatamente
assim está bom agora calma
como é que eu vejo que é meia noite eu
preciso encontrar o relógio está aqui
isso pronto só que eu vou ver agora por
estar longe quando é que vai ser uma
noite vai ser agora não
não não falta falta uma volta dos
ponteiros do scud e eu acho que posso ir
lá bater pessoal eu vou tentar bater
já as 21 vez porque supostamente o
último é que tem que ser exatamente
também não toca e d deixem só ver se se
acumula ao que estou como o exato eu
posso me afastar um pouco quando voltar
a bater a estatal quer os alvos a abater
a 21 e isso agora vou ver as horas calma
deixa eu acho que é mesmo quase
meia-noite em qualquer pessoal quando
faltarem por aí uns 10 segundos eu corro
pra porta na quase pessoal tá quase nós
temos quase ficar o bicho eu espero
agora conseguir acender a vela andar
não é que eu consegui encontrar nas
lojas porque senão eu não gostaria
preparar o bairro a cair vamos vamos
vamos vamos a quase meia noite e
roteiros para vela e agora a ser muito
rápido muito rápido e isso tem buscado
dar qualquer hora foi agora foi pessoal
nós temos que andar agora temos que
sobreviver até às 13 33 da manhã
ok bora lá agora vai conseguir pelo
menos a conseguir vamos ter um quarto de
uma criança ou a fugir pois vejo maior
só de compra fácil ficar sem impostos só
fiquei sem impostos só fiquei sem fosse
hoje eu fiquei sem fala em fotos
ficassem aqui futebol você está a pagar
através de não conseguir cerca de mil
eu não vou conseguir ser mais fácil
demais mas o que mais porque mais nada o
pessoal agora vamos ter que sobreviver é
aqui dentro sem foco em fósforos carmo
32 o que é preciso encontrar mais mais
mais fácil falar hoje eu quero mais
forte no hospital
anda anda tudo outra vez não
também é difícil você nessa [ __ ] isso
anda anda nunca nunca nunca advogado
advogado calma calma e evite uma porta
para que a mostra casa de banho é na
casa mas não era calma não tem nada da
casa ainda vemos por aqui não já tinha
entrado aqui pessoal do produto permite
a cada casa só que vamos porque vamos
pra ninguém
ok é o embate deve ser mais seguro por
isso vamos jogar só já só tem um forte
foi preciso encontrar mais seu que meu
jogo de ida quando olha pessoal eu já
não sei quanto andar e ele acha que
atuam fora da casa
não há chuveiros de chuva
o gato ao eu acho que tô fora da casa
meu ou não este é um só tem uma coisa
assim
logan barris e caixas
só não sei nem o túnel como pode
machucar fora eu acho tocar fora centro
podem trocar entre porque é um sindicato
forte
calma eu possa fazer a não ser as luzes
calma não possa acender as luzes porque
faz parte do ritual não tem escada
humana la quando ela tem com o esporte
os dois já têm a ganhar força nos melhor
jogado só tenha gasto em uma perícia
anda lá pra cima anda lá só nós vamos
ter que conseguir aguentar até às 13 33
da manhã meu ok mas mais forte funciona
lá nada nada
ela transmitiu do piloto ouviu as lojas
por meio do youtube agora pessoa já não
saiu da cultura o meu caso é muito
grande
a casa é muito fraquinho grande mel é o
quarto lugar não puxo em quatro finais é
bom é bom andar de uma gaveta
o filme evento é meu não posso ficar
muito tempo parado só saiu lhe pela
campanha pública
o grupo voltou a arrombar a porta mesmo
tamanho na porta da casa dela em uma
favela
o tempo do cabelo bicho eu tenho muito
cabelo eu juro que há uma câmera simples
e um baú com fósforo não tô falando
claro olga tenta aumentar na etapa
atender isto é de tal forma o trio de
terrorismo de cantar eu preciso de ajuda
as rochas mas não encontraram o cosmu
cantar e tocar fogo
vamos embora daqui mas é meu chamaria
isso de uma maneira boa porque qualquer
pessoa é muito complicado assim neste
forte por dilton ter uma sorte o caraças
meu
já entre outras bem sangue
huck no twitter agora pude ir outra vez
de o bb vai apanhar em casa não pode ser
meu
tudo preto e eu vamos saltar para cima
tá tudo preto vai voltar pro senhor é um
toque pessoal não consegue chegar até às
3 e 33 também é mas já valeu o esforço
por isso deixa o flick favorito e se
querem ver um vídeo dilma conseguir
passar este jogo
digo embaixo só vez foi apenas a
primeira tentativa não sabe que será
assim tão difícil mas querem ver mais
dominante que indicam embaixo pessoal
deixa o vosso apoio fiquem bem e até a
próxima
[Música]